bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous ses
sens public votre rendez-vous de débats
de reportages et des expertises sur
public sénat voici le sommaire de ce 2
février de 2,22 une date à un chiffre on
vivra sa et une seule fois dans nos vies
mais c'est pas notre sommaire on
commence avec les jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin qui démarre
officiellement dans deux jours ils se
feront à 100% sur neige artificielle
aberration écologique dit yannick jadot
qui appellent au boycott diplomatique on
va débattre autour des enjeux
géopolitiques financiers et humanitaire
de ces jo les maires des petites villes
sous pression certains se disent
harcelés par les candidats qui cherchent
des parrainages
reportage en essonne à nausées et à
leuville sur orge et puis quatre
millions cinq cent mille personnes ont
démissionné au mois de novembre dernier
aux états unis la france est-elle
également confronté à une vague de
démissions le télétravail va-t-il
s'installer durablement la semaine de
quatre jours peut-elle s'imposer dans
des grands groupes comme total énergie
c'est l'avenir de notre organisation du
travail que l'on va explorer tout à
l'heure dans notre second débat mais
d'abord donc ces jeux d'hiver qui
devrait être une fête mais qui charrie
un lot de polémiques
de plus en plus lourds jonathan des
prises c'est dans un climat diplomatique
glacial que s'ouvrent les jeux
olympiques d'hiver à pékin loin de
l'état de grâce qui régnait en 2008 lors
des jo d'été l'heure est aux polémiques
plusieurs pays à commencer par les
etats-unis ont décidé un boycott
diplomatique de l'événement washington
accusant pékin de génocide sur la
minorité ouïghoure côté chinois rien ne
semble pouvoir perturber l'événement
en 2008 pékin a accueilli djo sans
précédent qui ont été saluées par le
monde entier quatorze ans plus tard nous
sommes réunis pour une olympiade simple
sûr et spectaculaire côté français en
revanche silence radio sur la question
du boycott c'est ce que déplore le
sénateur michel savin beaucoup de pays
ont été très silencieux est aujourd'hui
aussi le silence est quand même assez
retentissant du côté français notamment
du prêt dans la république qui préside
aussi l'europe on aurait peut-être pu
s'attendre à une déclaration sur ce
point l'événement est aussi très
critiqué sur le plan environnemental la
chine vende pourtant l'utilisation de
technologies vertes mais ces jeux seront
les premiers à reposer intégralement sur
l'utilisation de neige artificielle
produite par des canons de ce type un
désastre écologique que dénonce
guillaume gontard le réchauffement
climatique dont on voit les effets tous
les jours on se dit qu'on pourrait quand
même prendre conscience et non on va
faire des jo sans % en neige
artificielle
franchement quand on voit les images
quand on voit ces montagnes avec ses
filets de neige avec avec uniquement la
neige artificielle dire c'est pas
compréhensible à cela s'ajoute la menace
du coc vide qui planent toujours sur
l'épreuve malgré une bulle sanitaires
très strictes pour limiter les risques
la chine a annulé la vente de billets et
les épreuves se tiendront presque à huit
clos à deux jours de la cérémonie
d'ouverture
l'heure n'est donc pas vraiment à la
fête à pékin faut-il boycotter ces jeux
olympiques voilà le thème de notre débat
je vous présente mes invités marie
cécile nav bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
politologue directrice de recherche à
l'iris membre du comité scientifique de
sport et citoyenneté jean philippe béja
bonjour mieux vaut aussi directeur de
recherche émérite au cnrs et ceri
sciences po spécialiste de la politique
chinoise corinne boulloud bon soin
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
sports olympiques matthieu croissandeau
évidemment à mes côtés comme tous les
mercredis dans la liste politique
bonsoir mathieu une petite liste pour
commencer deux pays qui ont annoncé un
boycott diplomatique des jeux de pékin
les états unis royaume uni australie
canada nouvelle zélande
lituanie danemark pays bas japon est ce
que la france doit rejoindre cette liste
marie cécile navx qui souvent pensé une
sans que le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonne a dit
que roxana maracineanu donc la ministre
déléguée au sport allait se rendre à la
compétition pour soutenir les athlètes
et traquent les athlètes mais peut-être
boycotter la cérémonie d'ouverture c'est
un peu en même temps
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est difficile
de complètement boycotter cet événement
qui
en retentissement mondial est d'abord
une position claire parce que les
relations avec la chine sont très
importantes sur un plan économique pour
l'union européenne et pour la france je
lui particulièrement mais après c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi des déclarations de
la part de l'europe et une partie des
députés européens et de notre pays sur
les questions de droits humains génocide
et we go etc c'est une position qui est
très inconfortable pour les guérir les
gens qu'est ce que vous en pensez
au moins personnellement je passais pas
à mon moi je suis pas décideur politique
donc c'est pas à moi à dire moi je
puisse observatrice du réel mais ce qui
est ce qu'il va être intéressant aussi
devoir c'est ce qui ne boycotte pas et
qui vont s'afficher avec le président
chinois c'est particulièrement le cas de
vladimir poutine on en reparlera
peut-être tout à l'heure donc on voit
bien les pays qui boycottent la
cérémonie d'un tiers c'est plutôt les
pays occidentaux puissent le japon grand
rival de la chine dans la région qui lui
a lui aussi à organiser des jeux
olympiques l'an dernier de manière très
très compliqué sur la crise sanitaire
mais mais on va voir qui assiste
peut-être les pays d'europe centrale qui
ont aussi une carte à jouer avec la
chine puisqu'il a des intérêts
stratégiques pour eux dans cette région
là évidemment il ya du bizness derrière
jean philippe béja vous aviez a signé en
décembre dernier à une tribune appelant
au boycott diplomatique justement
pourquoi oui j'avais aussi signé en 2008
si vous voulez savoir des jeux
olympiques de pékin parce que je crois
que il est absolument in pour des
raisons qui ont été d'ailleurs dit au
cours de votre reportage il ya
énormément de problèmes avec les jeux
olympiques en général et avec ceux ci en
particulier est qu'un se trouve dans un
dans une région semi aride il
yad'énormes problèmes d'eau à pékin je
prends pas de neige je parle de cuir et
là on va commencer à utiliser énormément
de canons à neige etc on entre là dans
notre seconde partie de l'aspect
environnemental il est très très
important mais sur le logo et
géopolitique on va chômer notamment sur
la question des bribes si vous voulez
pas seulement sur la question de we go
il faut lui avoir depuis son deuxième
mandat notamment ses inkling a décidé de
faire taire complètement la société
chinoise il a commencé par les avocats
défenseurs des droits de l'homme il a
continué par toutes les ong
indépendantes et le
l'enfermement d'une grande partie des
ouigours des quasars et ddt des kirghiz
est aussi plus généralement d'ailleurs
la volonté d'éradiquer totalement les
cultures des minorités nationales on a
même vu les soulèvements en mongolie ce
qui n'était pas arrivé depuis 1949 donc
il ya un véritable problème de ce point
de vue là il ya un problème extrêmement
grave des droits de l'homme et puis il y
à un homme qui est en train de vouloir
devenir le grand timonier qui est en
train de re total y autoriser la chine
et de se mettre au centre même
de supprimer tout ce qui à tous les
progrès qui avait été fait au cours des
40 dernières années alors on peut au
moins manifesté son mécontentement
vis-à-vis de celui qui reste un
partenaire important sur la scène
internationale
et c'est justement là le hic il est
important de montrer son mécontentement
et d'essayer de faire un certain nombre
de pressions sur la chine et ça marche
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent on
va en parler de l'impact effectivement à
l'intérieur de
notamment au sein du pouvoir chinois
corinne boulloud convention se passe du
côté des athlètes alors on est plus au
moment de la guerre froide au boycott
était un boycott ont carrément on n'en
voyait pas de délégation est arrivée aux
jeux de moscou plongent de los angeles
là on parle de boycott diplomatique et
finalement est ce qu'on fait pas peser
trop d'enjeux sur les sur les sportifs
bien sûr que c'est une grand moment de à
chaque fois c'est c'est effectivement la
même chose ça et ça l'a été à pékin il y
avait des appels au boycott mais ce ne
sont pas aux sportifs de devoir
supporter je dire ce qui est politique
avant tout une décision politique et
puis ça se décide sept ans avant une
désignation de ville hôte des jeux
olympiques
donc ces sept ans avant et notamment le
cio qui prend cette décision qui doit
engager ses réflexions sept ans après la
les sportifs ils se sont préparés depuis
80 depuis la fin des jeux à pyeong chang
en corée en 2010 8 pour préparer ces
jeux là et pour aller chercher les
médailles et peut-être pour l'équipe de
france olympique allé battre un record
de médailles s'il ya quand même une
drôle d'ambiance kourina à pékin et sur
les sites il ya d'abord cette cellule
sanitaire c'est quand même on voit les
premières images c'est quand rose
particulièrement morose ça l'était déjà
à tokyo l été dernier la salle l'est
encore plus parce que les chinois une
politique du zéro que vides
donc ils ont une frayeur par rapport à
ça c'est ce qu'ils veulent installer oui
maintenant ils n'y arriveront pas parce
qu'il ya de plus de 200 personnes qui
ont été testées justement avant
d'arriver ou même là en ce moment alors
ces personnes là sont mises à
l'isolément mais pour avant d'arriver en
chine c'est tout un protocole est un
processus à suivre ses 14 jours avant
ceux qui sont là bas qu'ils devaient
faire quotidiennement un bulletin de
santé il ya des tests pcr maintenant
qu'ils sont dans la bulle quand vous y
rentrer et qui sont faits
quotidiennement
oropharyngée d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai
que ça se mérite
et puis il ya un côté bienvenue chez big
brother parce que il ya une société
canadienne spécialisée dans la cyber
sécurité
marie-cécile 9 qui met en garde les
athlètes sur un risque d'espionnage via
leur smartphone c'est ça oui parce qu'il
ya une application que la chine demande
aux participants donc ce car les
athlètes l'entourage le staff que ça et
aussi journalisme de télécharger
my
chitwan site où le nom donc un peu comme
notre notre
application tout senti qu vide mais
alors là vraiment il ya des très très
grosse suspicion à la fois de piratage
informatique mais aussi de
d'aspiration des données personnelles
par la chine on sait que c'est chaque
fois que vous allez en chine il faut pas
lui mais sans téléphone portable voire
pas l'emmener ni son ordinateur parce
que l'état chinois entre tout de suite
dans vos appareils dont plusieurs
délégations olympiques ont demandé à
leurs aux athlètes de ne pas partir avec
leur propre leur propre matériel
informatique leur donner des ce
téléphone jetable est ce tu as donc
c'est un enjeu quand même
intéressant de rappeler ce soit jean
philippe béja ça va on peut le dire
cette bulle sanitaire 7 ce climat
particulier réduire quasiment à néant
les contacts entre les sportifs ou même
les journalistes et la population
chinoise ça ça va très bien au
pouvoir chinois c'est ce qu'ils
cherchent pas eu envie de dire si
coville existait pas il aurait fallu
l'inventer et ça a permis véritablement
de renforcer énormément les contrôles
sur l'ensemble de la société et là c'est
extraordinaire vous avez donc des
centaines peut-être des milliers de
journalistes qui vont arriver à pékin et
qui ne rencontreront pas un chinois tout
ça vous ne pouvez pas aller interviewer
des gens dans les rues ça veut dire
qu'en 2008 ah oui ce sera pire qu'en
2008 veut dire en 2008 vous savoir effet
s'endort le comité international
olympique avait demandé qu'il y ait des
espaces de liberté il y avait trois
espaces de liberté pour laquelle il
fallait s'inscrire et les trois
personnes qui sont pas dus le protesté
se sont retrouvés en prison après ça
c'est un autre temps mais là ils
ramènent pas ça c'est à dire que on a
faim on a avancé dans la sûreté de soi
du régime chinois c'est à dire que c'est
une clean en fait maintenant 10
simplement voilà c'est dans ces
conditions vous viendrez et alors ça se
passe bien sûr avec les jeux olympiques
il faut bien voir que quelques mois
depuis depuis un ou deux ans un certain
nombre de journalistes ont été interdits
de chine même en compte je veux dire des
idées des journalistes ont vu leurs vues
on n'a pas besoin de visa pour aller
encore ils ont vu leurs visas refusés
aujourd'hui un professeur de droit de
l'université de hong kong vient de se
voir notifier le refus de visa et des
professeurs de droit de l'homme donc ce
qui se passe c'est que l'on cherche par
tous les moyens à isoler la population
chinoise de l'ensemble des journalistes
étrangers mais ça c'est se situe
directement dans la politique de cité
mais on essaye de faire taire toutes
opinions divergent et d'empêcher et de
les empêcher de s'exprimer donc ces
jeux-là participer à ces jeux olympiques
couvrir ces jeux olympiques ça fait ça
donne l'impression que finalement on
peut faire ça de façon presque normal et
je crois que ça s'est extrêmement gênant
pour pour la l'image même de nos
journalistes sportifs de notes nous nos
médias et bien sûr ça renforce le régime
de sidi ifni et ça pose mathieu la
question des réactions de la classe
politique de notre classe politique en
france elles sont pour le moins timide
oui pour le moins il ya même une forme
de complaisance française vis-à-vis de
la chine aucune dictature au monde ne
bénéficie de ce régime de faveur au sein
de la classe politique et ce presque
tous bords confondus tenez rien que le
mot dictature qu'il emploie aujourd'hui
quand il parle de la chine sur la scène
politique personne au mieux on parle de
régimes autoritaires et pourtant tous
les universitaires les chercheurs enfin
vous venez de le dire je parle sous
votre contrôle qualifie ce régime qui
évidemment réprime sa population mais
surtout ce régime basé sur un parti
unique sans liberté d'opinion sur
liberté d'expression sans liberté
d'information qui exerce à la fois une
surveillance et une censure sur ses
concitoyens
qui enferme à tour de bras tous les
opposants vous l'avez dit les avocats
les défenseurs des intellectuels bref
tous les qui réprime au point qu'on se
demande si c'est pas s'il faut pas
qualifiés de génocide ces minorités
musulmanes mais qui réprime aussi depuis
des décennies au tibet à hong kong qui
expulse les journalistes bref on
pourrait continuer la liste
oui mais voilà quand on parle de région
chinois en france les politiques
français ont encore des pudeurs de
gazelle alors j'emploie cette expression
à dessein parce qu'elle appartient à
jean luc mélenchon qui aveuglé par son
tropisme pro chinois est contraint à de
grands écarts dignes d'une épreuve de
ski acrobatique sur neige artificielle
rendez vous compte le voilà qui invite
les bleus à boycotter la coupe du monde
au qatar parce que ce serait jouer sur
des cadavres explique-t-il en faisant
référence à ses 6500 ouvriers philippins
disparu dans la construction des stades
mais qui refuse à appeler au boycott des
jeux de pékin combien de cadavres lui
faut-il à jean luc mélenchon le même
jean luc mélenchon jamais à court de
sophismes quand il s'agit de la chine a
refusé de voter une résolution
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
reconnaissant le génocide des ouigours
tenez vous bien parce que si c'était un
génocide alors il faudrait se donner les
moyens d'intervenir
franchement il était intéressant ce vote
en même temps 175 votants sur 577
députés et des absents de marque
le rassemblement national pas un député
a participé au vote des républicains dix
votants sur son de membres et pas un
seul cador à commencer par le patron du
groupe républicain damien abad peut-être
parce qu'il est vice président du groupe
d'amitié france chine tient comme jean
luc mélenchon
eric zemmour lui avait refusé le boycott
car ce serait laisser ce ça serait se
laisser emmener par les états unis dans
une guerre au nom de la démocratie
disait-il au moins tout est dit ou assez
clair mais valérie pécresse vous avez
entendu anne hidalgo vous l'avez entendu
non rares sont les voix fortes comme
celle de l'eurodéputé raphaël glucksmann
qui en a fait un de ses combats
personnels ou du candidat écologiste
yannick jadot qui avait lui appelé au
boycott des jeux olympiques on écoute
j'ai appelé le président de la
république a envoyé aucun représentant
à aux jeux olympiques de chine
un boycott diplomatique
je veux je veux pas prendre en otage les
sportifs c'est pas les sportifs qu'on
choisit de donner les jo d'hiver à la
chine s'est pas laissé des footballeurs
qu'on choisit qu'on fasse une coupe du
monde au qatar qui a tué six mille cinq
cents migrants qu'on travaille dans des
conditions abominables pour construire
les stades donc moi je prend pas en
otage les sportifs
en passant sa rivale malheureuse
sandrine rousseau a twitté sur la chine
hier pour condamner les jeux olympiques
les plus polluantes de l'histoire pour
défendre gour pas du tout pour souhaiter
à tous ses followers en idéogrammes
chinois s'il vous plaît une bonne année
du tigre complaisance tiens et du côté
de l'exécutif mais du côté l'exécutif
emmanuel macron a bien condamner
publiquement en 2020 la pression des
ouïgours il a même assuré au printemps
dernier avoir échangé sur ce sujet avec
au xi jingping mais pas question de
boycott et d'expliquer au mois de
décembre dernier ce serait une décision
toute petite et symbolique a déclaré le
président et y envoyer comme seule
représentante de la france la ministre
des sports roxana maracineanu du 11 au
15 février et absente de la cérémonie
d'ouverture ce n'est pas une décision
toute petite elle fabrique
merci mathieu jean philippe béja c'est
nouveau cette complaisance soit les
pires mais avant elle est ancienne elle
est ancienne pas pire qu'avant non le
seul moment où il ya eu véritablement
une absence de complaisance et une
véritable fermeté sur les droits de
l'homme c'est au lendemain du massacre
du 4 juin 1989 lorsque françois
mitterrand avait pris des mesures et des
sanctions n'était pas le seul mais la
france était à l'époque à l'avant garde
contre le régime de deux lits
prud'hommes serbie si vous voulez il ya
des intérêts économiques comme le disait
ma table bien sûr ça c'est évident mais
vous savez les chinois sont des
réalistes et même si vous vous souciez
vous si vous voulez critiquer si vos
produits sur les meilleurs ils
achèteront beaux produits il faut bien
voir que ne saisiront pas contre leurs
propres intérêts parra maison de
retraite bien entendu peut-être qu'ils
reprirent pousseront de six mois la
signature d'un contrat alors c'est très
grave pour un élu bien sûr si vous avez
des élections présidentielles à ce
moment là c'est très gênant mais enfin
si on a une certaine fermeté une
certaine constance il n'y a aucun
problème
les d'ailleurs si vous regardez la
courbe des échevins de l'attitude
française vis-à-vis de la chine et la
courbe du commerce vous verrez que
lorsqu'on fait un maximum de concessions
on n'augmente pas le commerce franco
chinois un gala recueil qui a été
souvent assez ferme avec les chinois
l'allemagne à 5 frein encore ta commerce
extérieur excédentaire avec la chine et
les cinq fois supérieur au nôtre donc je
crois que là c'est un rêve qu'on a donc
les raisons économiques si vous voulez
elle ne marche pas alors il y en a une
autre vous savez c'est une très vieille
civilisation et je suis tout à fait
d'accord et c'est une civilisation
impressionnante mais est-ce que si jean
py représente véritablement lâché donc
ce qui me gêne c'est quand on parle
toujours de la chine non on ne parle pas
de la chine nous parlons du parti
communiste chinois moi je suis
absolument favorable au maximum de
relation au développement de toutes les
relations avec la chine avec les chinois
avec la société chinoise l'at-il le
problème qui se pose c'est doit-on
encourager un dirigeant qui est en train
non seulement de métro pas mais de
mettre entre me de m offert la société
de son pays pas seulement les ouigours
pas seulement les tibétains mais
véritablement aussi les ramener chinois
mais ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
ça donc je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention je crois pour toi être
complaisant vis-à-vis d'un tel régime je
ne le comprends pas alors vous vous
parliez de la complaisance vous avez
c'est que vous avez fait écouter la
réaction de yannick jadot c'est
intéressant quand un cadenas vous pouvez
nous nous rejoindre parce que cette
question soit content
cette question du boycott des jeux
olympiques elle s'est invitée
aujourd'hui même au sénat exactement
c'est tout à l'heure lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec une
question d'un élu écologiste 1 c'est pas
anodin celle de thomas d'hossus il a
commencé par rail et thomas les pistes
de ski 100% artificielle installés sur
des montagnes arides je cite en plein
milieu d'une réserve naturelle avant de
faire la longue liste que vous avez un
peu commencé tout à l'heure un monsieur
de toutes les dérives du régime chinois
presse mise sous coupe réglée en je cite
encore taïwan sous la menace sort des
ouigours bien sûr et ailleurs selon
l'écologiste ce génocide des ouigours
telle colère qualifiée il ya encore
quelques semaines un par les députés eh
bien ça suffirait à lui seul a motivé le
boycott des représentants français à pk
écoutez donc thomas do cieux élu e élevé
du rhône s'il ya un génocide en cours
alors se pose à minima la question du
boycott diplomatique des jeux c'est la
voie qu'ont adopté les états unis le
royaume uni le canada ou encore
l'australie le 20 janvier dernier franck
riester déclaré face à la gravité de la
situation la france dénonce avec force
et de manière constante ces pratiques
inqualifiables et injustifiable ma
question est donc la suivante madame la
ministre cette force et cette constance
s'arrête-t-elle à la porte des tribunes
officielles des jeux de pékin allez vous
par votre présence légitime et la
brutalité du régime chinois et donc tome
1 le gouvernement a pu répondre par la
voix de roxana maracineanu elle a
commencé par parler d'un dialogue je
cite exigeant avec la chine elle a dit
travailler avec amnesty international au
fait de responsabiliser davantage le
monde du sport dans l'attribution des
compétitions sportives notamment après
ce qui s'est passé avec et bien la coupe
du monde au qatar où donc ces jeux de
pékin avant d'ajouter que la politique
de la chaise vide n'était pas la bonne
solution écouter la suite je vous
rassure monsieur le sénateur ma présence
ou soutien de notre délégation à pékin
n'affecte en aucune manière la position
de la france sur ces sujets
les droits de l'homme comme sur tous les
autres
si je vais à pékin c'est pour être en
soutien de nos athlètes autant de sports
ce qui s'entraîne depuis quatre ans est
l'objet de leur vie nous leur devons le
respect et moi ma mission en tant que
ministre des sports c'est d'être à leurs
côtés et je compte la remplir avec
responsabilité et en toute conscience de
ce que je représente en tant que
ministre des sports et la parole que je
porte au nom de la france en étant
présentes en chine on voit là thomas 1
pour cette réponse qui avait donc l'oeil
à quelques-uns dans l'hémicycle du sénat
un dernier mot pour mentionner la
réplique de la gauche après cette
réponse ça n'a pas du tout convaincu les
écologistes puisque thomas dessus a fini
à rajouter en disant qu'il fallait
arrêter le slalom face à la chine avec
d'un côté ce mot génocide pour qualifier
un ce qui se passe avec les ouigours et
donc l'autre côté le refus de boycotter
les jeux merci quentin pour ses
explications je voudrais qu'on parle
maintenant ensemble de l'impact d'un
boycott ou de la mobilisation d'une
opinion publique internationale face à
la signer et pour cela s'appuyer sur
l'histoire de pine trail corinne
boulloud peng shuai c'est une joueuse de
tennis professionnelle qui avait disparu
après avoir accusé de viol un ancien
vice-premier ministre chinois zhang
gaoli depuis elle a fait quelques
apparitions très orchestrée on va dire
par le pouvoir chinois le président du
comité international olympique ça va
être intéressant d'analyser ce ce qui
dit il marche sur des oeufs dans dans ce
dossier très clairement carrément oui
forcément thomas ce bar est dans une
situation compliquée à pékin il a assuré
qu'il allait rencontrer pentile parce
que pour le moment il dit l'avoir eu en
visio mais c'était des moments très
compliqués elle n'avait pas évidemment
liberté de parole et
mais après avoir disparu des écrans
radars pendant un petit moment tout le
monde s'inquiétait les joueurs de tennis
ont commencé à s'emparer du
sujet et a demandé des nouvelles le
président on va voir du cio on va voir
si effectivement il va pouvoir
rencontrer pengfei mais ça c'est une
épine dans le pied de pékin pour ces
jeux parce que forcément 7 c'est devenu
un emblème
justement de la contestation a pas l 'un
parce que je ne sais pas si elle le
souhaitait mais n'empêche qu'elle a eu
un courage extraordinaire de d'accuser
un haut dignitaire chinois et c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué hein
d'avoir des soutiens sportifs et le
président du cio on va voir s'il va voir
il va pouvoir avoir une discussion libre
entre guillemets avec nike et pour
l'instant il a été plutôt profil bas
moins courageux que l'américain steve
simmons qui est le président de la wta
donc c'est le circuit de tennis féminin
est pourtant maïs et syna c'est ont
parlé de business tout à l'heure la
chine et l'asie pour le circuit pro
féminin de tennis est un gros enjeu
financier et un marché potentiel
important et non mais on voit que
l'engagement en faveur des droits
humains dans le monde du sport prend de
l'ampleur ces dernières années or cio
parce que c'est avec le cio est quand
même très très complaisant avec avec ça
il faut le dire la fifa aussi avec avec
le qatar on vous dira un mot du 14 mai
mais il ya en voit quand même que ça
bouge parce qu'il ya une opinion
publique qui est sensible à ça c'est
aussi déçu des supporters des
spectateurs spectatrice qui sont
sensibles à ces enjeux dont il ya des
des questions aussi de fidélité du
public c'est des gens jo économique
aussi une certaine manière m'envoie que
le monde du sport se se se mobilisent
quand même de plus en plus et il se
passera rien pour
mes jeux ce donga oblige condom
certainement très mal cet ancien
vice-premier ministre jean philippe béja
qu'il représente il est surpuissant en
chine où beaucoup moins qu'avant c'est
vous savez c'est un des régimes les plus
opaques du nom dont pour savoir
exactement quelle est l'influencé
aujourd'hui de zhang gaoli disons que
c'est tout de même une personnalité qui
est très haut placé puisqu'il était
membre du comité vice-ministre service
prenez ça veut rien dire un gouvernement
chine ça compte ce qui compte c'est le
parti il était membre du comité
permanent du bureau politique c'est à
dire les sept ou neuf personnes qui
dirigent la chine donc c'était quelque
chose de très important mais il a été
dénoncé quand ils avaient déjà à la
retraite donc il a encore certainement
une influence aussi nous le savons
savons pas exactement leur contenu des
luttes au sommet du parti communiste
dans quelle mesure est ce que l'afld le
capital post2 de prince charles a pu
passer et dans quelle mesure est ce
qu'il y avait derrière ce qu'on appelle
en chine souvent un
environnement des coulisses qui ont aidé
le c'est quelque chose qu'on ne sait pas
mais disons que c'est quand même
quelqu'un de très très importante mais
cette émotion dans le monde du sport et
cette prise de conscience internationale
sur les droits humains elle est
intéressante mais elle devrait aussi se
retourner contre les grandes
organisations internationales parce que
j'ai on peut blâmer et il faut blâmer la
dictature chinoise mais il faut aussi
blâmé le cio ou la fifa on en parlait il
faut savoir que les jeux olympiques
c'est la vitrine suprême de ce qu'on
appelle le soft power
diplomatie influences qui permet pour un
pays d'afficher une bonne image et on
offre ça à des régimes qui sont
inqualifiables je viens au nom d'accord
parfois parfois de dessous de table on
l'a vu pour la fifa parfois d'accord
diplomatiques parfois des jeux de vote
truqué ou non rien et à un moment il
faut que l'opinion se retourne contre
ceux qui attribuent ces jeux à des
régimes qui sont plus près comment faire
il y avait que deux candidats aux jeux
olympiques aux jeux olympiques
se sont désistés petit le kazakhstan et
pékin et le seco pour
le gigantisme même de ces et notamment
la gouvernance de ces grandes
organisations internationales sont pas
du tout des mots que l'accord les deux
précités effectivement en dehors du
droit commun
service est en train d'être vu par le
seuil haut puisque justement pour éviter
cette cascade de forfaits de villes
candidates là ils ont par exemple pour
2030 deux ils ont choisi brisbane alors
que le qatar voulait absolument
organiser les jeux il a même été étonné
à un taux de cd4
les jeux d'hiver ça aurait été gonflé
pk est bien la première ville
mais mais c'est vrai que le seuil haut
là pour 2022 pour des questions
financières
c'est ça s'est retrouvé avec deux
candidatures assez étonnant de quoi
c'est à dire pékin pour organiser des
jeux d'hiver et almaty au kazakhstan qui
est pas non plus un gym on a
le choix entre la peste et je voudrais
qu'on parle d'eux de la question vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
environnementale et ça rejoint ce a
rejoint évidemment tous les tous les
thèmes dont on parle maintenant sur
cette neige artificielle dont vous avez
cité yannick jadot sur les droits de
l'homme et voilà ce qui twittait une
rock star il ya deux jours 100% de la
neige utilisée pour les jo de pékin sera
artificielle ça représente près de 185
millions de litres d'eau utilisée pour
l'écologie et les droits humains il y
revient et il appelle de nouveau au
boycott diplomatique corinne boulloud
est ce que c'est une première tient des
jo d'hiver 100% surnage artificielle
100% oui alors on va jouer sur les
pourcentages oui encore et au moins
j'étais il ya quatre ans c'était 90 %
les pistes étaient c'était de la neige
artificielle envoyer les canes ont
fonctionné à plein temps et à sotchi en
2014 c'est que tu es 80% sur neige
artificielle avec des jeux qui en pour
les épreuves alpines avaient été
construits les infrastructures de 1 à z
on était près de la mer noire là c'est
comme si vous organisez les jeux près de
la méditerranée un saut trop peu voilà
ce soit revue c'est ça c'est le saint
tropez un russe donc ça mais en plus en
va dans le les années et là on est à
100% de neige artificielle avec des
canons à neige qui ont commencé à
travailler je crois depuis mi novembre
alors c'est vrai que écologiquement ça
paraît complètement fou donc on voit on
me parlait de catastrophes écologiques
et pourtant jean philippe béja si on
essaye de mettre un tout petit bémol la
chine est sensible aussi à ces arguments
elle fait d'effort ou en tout cas elle
montre qu'elle fait des efforts en
matière environnementale oui mais faux
pas face à la l'impact de la propagande
c'est ça ça pèse pas lourd vous savez
bien sûr non ce qui se passe c'est que
il ya énormément de la satisfaction de
la population chinoise vis-à-vis de la
dégradation de l'environnement est
notamment de la pollution dans les
grandes villes et cas c'était quand même
quelque chose de très connu mais ce qui
se passe mais mais en l'occurrence il
faut bien voir les canons à neige c'est
un scandale bien sûr mais je répète
pékin se trouve dans une zone semi aride
pékin à 20 millions d'habitants si on
compte l'ensemble de la municipalité et
il y a des problèmes d'approvisionnement
en eau depuis toujours les réservoirs au
tour de demi lune et d'ailleurs sont à
des niveaux très bas donc ils adorent
seulement un problème de neige
artificielle mais il ya un problème
d'eau organiser des jeux olympiques
d'hiver à pékin c'est un délire comme
celui de sotchi où comme organiser une
coupe du monde de football au qatar dans
le désert où il n'y a pas d'air et de
remise à 200 pensant climatisée du
bateau personne ne peut couvrir enfin je
veux dire jusqu'où va aller la
financiarisation le délire du sport
international
c'est effectivement un deux premiers il
ya le problème de la chine il ya le
problème de l'environnement et tout ça
mais il ya aussi le problème de c2c
espèce d'énorme
d'énormes raout qui n'ont aucun qui ne
prennent absolument pas en compte la
halle et les conditions matérielles il
conditions réelles ils sont aussi
délirant que le parti communiste chinois
avait vis-à-vis de la rue alors vous
vous donnez la parole juste après mais
il ya quand même un mouvement au sein du
du sport pour organiser des compétitions
sportives plus propre et c'est justement
ce que propose
julien pierre ancien international de
rugby qui est avec nous en duplex en
visioconférence avec julien pierre qui a
créé fondé la société fair play for
planète bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
c'est quoi c'est un label
environnemental c'est ça
bonsoir merci beaucoup de la mutation
vous m'entendez bien c'est bon
je crois
oui simplement grenet est le premier
label environnemental pour les clubs
sportifs comme l'a dit moi je suis un
ancien sportif de haut niveau
sensibilisés depuis longtemps à la cause
environnementale et est persuadé que le
sport évidemment à un apparition
environnement mais aussi un impact très
fort sur cetet il peut changer les
mentalités
et j'ai changer les façons de consommer
quelque part
par son influence par son aspect
pédagogique
et du coup j'ai crié charger belge
prévoyance sociale génèse mais on
travaille avec l'ademe l'agencé la
transition écologique
survient utilisation de notre
référentiel et qui elle a travaillé
pendant six mois non mais allez-y mai
mais ça veut dire que vous pouvez
labellisés un club une compétition un
même un championnat entier par exemple
alors nous on s'est lancé il ya un peu
plus d'un an
on alla billy's et des clubs sur la base
de notre essai en ciel aujourd'hui il ya
très bien encore quelques de
d'événements on commence à travailler
quelques événements également où la
trêve on a travaillé que des clubs de
top 14 comme la section paloise comme
l'olympique lyonnais en ligue 1 comme le
havre en ligue 2 et on vient regarder
toutes les aspects du club évidemment
elle n'a pas la partie stade énergie
tout ce qui est fluide la partie
alimentation de la partie
sensibilisation la partie transport qui
représente
entre 60 et 80% des émissions de gaz à
effet serre que là il faut trouver des
solutions
il raconté mais quand on parle d'un
événement aussi aussi lourd que des jeux
olympiques en coupe du monde
est ce que quand vous voyez on disait le
qatar pour la coupe du monde pékin pour
des jeux d'hiver c'est absurde est-ce
que vous avez sentiment que c'est un peu
le sport de l'ancien monde ça que ça va
plus être possible
je re c'est en train de changer
véritablement je pense que les sportifs
sont de plus en plus la parole
où on est et on au sein faire le relais
et on a un comité d'éthique avec une
sportive qui était chez nous cécile
hernandez qui boycottent les les jeux
les caisses curieuse et qui boycotte de
plus en plus ces championnats excès en
salle les sportifs sont la bande et bien
sûr les sportifs sont impactés par les
chemins de gematik parce que on le sait
les études qui sont sortis demain on va
région n'ait le temps de stores cancon
qu'on pourra avoir parce qu'il fait trop
chaud parce qu'il vise les conditions ne
sont pas sont pas les quads donc
il est évident que le sto elle va être
impactée que le sport pour la russie ce
jeu là merci merci julien pierre je
rappelle que vous êtes le fondateur du
label environnemental fair play for
planète corinne boulloud je leur pose la
même question est ce que c'est les jeux
de l'ancien monde cela où est ce que
finalement les difficultés auxquelles je
mets des guillemets le cio est confronté
peu de co2 villes candidates parce que
ça coûte très cher et souvent ça en
dette les villes pour des décennies ça
ça va pas obliger le cio a continué de
faire des choix totalement absurde alors
le cio a quand même créé un agenda à ce
qu'ils ont appelé l'agenda 20-20
justement pour éviter cette inflation
budget
pour les jeux et avoir des budgets
raisonnée et raisonnable ce qui
normalement doit être le cas pour paris
deux mille adresses ils seront les
premiers jeux normalement à être
encadrés par cet agent bas 20 mais ça a
vraiment changé cela fait des années que
ce chaque nouvelle ville dit ce seront
les jeux les si
oui il faut vraiment tout pour épicer
dans la charte de toute façon qui a été
signé entre le cio et la ville candidate
devenu un ville hôte des jeux olympiques
normalement et ça doit être des jeux à
zéro empreinte carbone ça peut être déjà
mathieu relatif mais il peut être
dubitatif je te pour maman je suis
dubitatif parce que quand je vois les
valeurs de l'olympisme qui prône la
noble les principes de tolérance de paix
de fair play le nombre de non violence
et et d'absence de rivalité et qu'on
confie ça à pékin dans la charte des
valeurs olympiques geron pour aussi
s'asseoir sur les valeurs
environnementales comme et ce soit
aujourd'hui en life ball est sûre
l'esprit olympique là ils font vraiment
ils ont ils ont vraiment décidés
effectivement négocié un virage
important laissant maintenant ville aux
prochaines villes appareil à los angeles
brisbane pour l'été turin pour les
prochains jeux olympiques d'hiver le
soin de le faire en tout cas ils vont
avoir les projecteurs braqués sur marie
cécile est ce que c'est pas tout
simplement le gigantisme de c
de ces grands raouts olympiques ou en
coupe du monde look qui sont plus
adaptés au temps adapté à la transition
écologique oui c'est probable et
d'ailleurs 90% à des installations
olympiques pour parler de 1024 seront
des sites déjà existants et le reste ce
sera des constructions soit éphémère
soit de développement territorial et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la partie
héritage des jeux et c'est aussi parce
que paris s'est engagé et va faire des
études d'impact ça sera évaluée ensuite
en termes d'impact environnemental
sociétal ecsta de faire des jeux qui
soit environ environnement
environnementalement exemplaire que tu
les a obtenus et on signale quand même
que l'essentiel de l'argent qui finance
les jeux olympiques c'est de l'argent
privé de l'argent pris l'argent public
c'est essentiellement pour développer
des infrastructures
qui
connaissent un accès une accélération
dans leurs mises en place à l'occasion
de ces grands événements sportifs c'est
pas c'est pas les états qui finance les
jeux olympiques ni les villes oui jean
philippe béja lé la chine en
l'occurrence où le parti communiste
chinois ou le pouvoir chinois se
préoccupe assez peu de savoir si les
jeux verts vont leur apporter de
l'argent ou leur en coûter beaucoup ce
qu'on parlait ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure le soft power c'est ça le plus
important oui en l'occurrence c'est tout
c'est tout à fait évident enfin bon je
pense que coca cola va dépensé pas mal
d'argent d'autres ainsi que je lisais
récemment mais évidemment c'est le
dernier c'est le cadet de leurs soucis
l'important c'est de montrer au monde
que la chine est un grand pays moderne
qui est capable d'organiser de grandes
réunions internationales dans une grotte
sécurité notamment au moment où tout le
monde a peur du coc vide regardez comme
nous avons bien veilleuse mans réussi à
limiter à tuer la pandémie qui commun à
commencer ce nous mais s'ennuie pas et
donc il ya un véritable problème sur les
jeux olympiques je veux dire les chinois
ont eu lieu le parti communiste chinois
sont au contraire plus il ya de
gigantisme plus sas assange est de vos
yeux mieux c'est pour le pour le parti
donc c'est évidemment et il est ce le
cas aussi sans aucun doute pour le qatar
pour ça pour ça beaucoup de monde il ya
plein il y aura des candidats pour avoir
pour faire ce genre de toi quand on
parle de la charte écologique ça m'amuse
un peu parce que moi je me voyais à tous
jeunes et je me rappelle simplement que
pour londres 2012
on avait dit cette fois ci pas de gâchis
pas de gaspillage
ne vous inquiétez pas il y aura pas un
centime de dépenser ce sera quelque
chose qui servira qui servira à
l'ensemble ce sera des dvd est vrai
qu'en oui alors comme comme logements
sociaux
un naturel sur les quais de la tamise on
peut discuter je veux dire le très
franchement le village olympique alors
donc je pense qu'il ya effectivement
sept vols chaque fois le cas en 2008
enfin rappelez vous on a quand même
donné les jeux olympiques de pékin en
2008 ça fait beaucoup de bruit il ya eu
beaucoup d'appels au boycott
on les a redonné les jeux d'hiver en
2022 avec tout ce que nous venons de
dire comme donc moi personnellement je
suis très sceptique sur le lab la bonne
volonté du comité international on l'a
bien compris corinne molins dernier mot
pour dire que pour les sportifs c'est
quand même compliqué je me à pierre
parler d'une d'une skieuse qui
boycottent mais dans la charte des jeux
olympiques y sont ne sont pas censés les
sportifs a exprimé des opinions
politiques c'est à dire c'est même
interdit annoncé interdit vous pouvez
pas mettre un petit chapeau alors il ya
évidemment sur l'exemple des exemples
mais normalement c'est interdit c'est
vous pouvez être radiés des jeux
olympiques si vous montrer quoi que ce
soit un t-shirt par exemple sur le
podium sur un tee shirt par exemple par
exemple oui on n'est pas à l'abri 1 2
que ça se passe d'ailleurs à l'open
d'australie les jeux je rajoute ça mais
la direction du tournoi a distribué des
tee shirt
pour
sensibiliser à la situation de l'action
publique qu il le mettait on a vu des
images non ça c'était assez nouveau
est-ce que ça se passera à pékin je ne
pense pas que l'organisation osera
distribuer les t-shirts non ça c'est sûr
mais peut-être qu'à sportif lui faudra
le faire on verra bien merci beaucoup à
lui dit très très vite la présence de
vladimir poutine et la rencontre avec le
président chinois le jour même de
l'ouverture des jeux c'est très
important parce que c'est une image qui
est performative qui est adressé à
l'occident il en attention il ya un axe
sino russe qui est qui est là qui est
sur le plan stratégique sur le plan de
la conquête spatiale sur le plan
militaire sur le plan économique qui est
là si vous vous nous écoutez nous on est
là pour manifester notre notre alliance
est notre force
voilà faute de bail donne on à poutine
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé